[Music]
in 1962 Charles Van Doren who was later
a senior editor at Britannica said the
ideal encyclopedia should be radical it
should stop being safe but if you know
anything about the history of Britannica
since 1962 was anything but radical
still a very completely safe stodgy type
of encyclopedia Wikipedia on the other
hand begins with a very radical idea and
that's for all of us to imagine a world
in which every single person on the
planet is given free access to the sum
of all human knowledge and that's what
we're doing so Wikipedia you just saw
the little demonstration of it
it's a freely licensed encyclopedia it's
written by thousands of volunteers all
over the world in many many languages
it's written using wiki software which
is the type of software he just
demonstrated so anyone can quickly edit
and save and it goes live on the
internet immediately and everything
about Wikipedia is managed by virtually
an all-volunteer staff so when yoga is
talking about new methods of
organization he's exactly describing
Wikipedia and what I'm gonna do today is
tell you a little bit more about how it
really works
on the inside so Wikipedia is owned by
the Wikimedia Foundation which I founded
a nonprofit organization and our goal
the the core aim of the Wikimedia
Foundation is to get a free encyclopedia
to every single person on the planet and
so if you think about what that means it
means a lot more than just building a
cool website we're really interested in
all the issues of the digital divide
poverty worldwide empowering people
everywhere to have the information that
they need to make good decisions and so
we're gonna have to do a lot of work
that goes beyond just the internet and
so that's a big part of why we've chosen
the free licensing model because that
empowers local entrepreneurs or anyone
who wants to can take our content and do
anything they like with it you can copy
it redistribute it and you can do it
commercially or non commercially so
there's a lot of opportunities that are
going to arise around Wikipedia all over
the world we're funded by donations from
the public and one of the more
interesting things about that is how
little money it actually takes to run
Wikipedia so yo-kai showed you the graph
of what the
of a printing press was and I'm gonna
tell you what the cost of Wikipedia is
but first I'll show you how big it is so
we've got over 600,000 articles in
English we've got 2 million total
articles across many many different
languages the biggest languages are
German Japanese French all the Western
European languages are quite big but
only around 1/3 of all of our traffic to
the to our web clusters to the English
Wikipedia which is surprising to a lot
of people a lot of people think in a
very English centric way on the Internet
but for us we're truly global we're in
many many languages how popular we've
gotten to be we're a top 50 web site and
we're more popular than the New York
Times so this is where we get to yokai's
discussion this shows the growth of
Wikipedia we're the blue line there and
then this is the New York Times over
there and what's interesting about this
is that the New York Times website is a
huge enormous corporate operation with I
have no idea how many hundreds of
employees we have exactly one employee
and that employee is our lead software
developer and he's only been our
employee since January 2005 all the
other growth before that so the servers
are managed by a ragtag band of
volunteers all the editing is done by
volunteers and the way that we're
organized is not like any traditional
organization you can imagine people are
always asking well who's in charge of
this or who does that and the answer is
anybody who wants to pitch in it's a
very unusual and chaotic thing we've got
over 90 servers now in three locations
these are managed by volunteer system
administrators who are online I can go
online any time of the day or night and
see 8 to 10 people waiting for me to ask
a question or something anything about
the servers you could never afford to do
this in a company you can never afford
to have a standby crew of people 24
hours a day and do what we're doing at
Wikipedia so we're doing around 1.4
billion page views monthly so it's
really going to be a huge thing and all
everything is managed by the volunteers
and the total monthly cost for our
bandwidth is about $5,000 and that's
essentially I'm
cost we could actually do without the
employee we we actually hired Brian
because he was working part-time for two
years and full-time at Wikipedia so we
actually hired him so he could get a
life and go to the movies sometimes so
the big question when you've got this
really chaotic organization is why isn't
it all rubbish why is the website as
good as it is first of all how good is
it no it's pretty good it isn't perfect
but it's much much better than you would
expect given our completely chaotic
model so when you saw him make a
ridiculous edit to the page about me you
think well this is obviously just going
to degenerate into rubbish but when
we've seen quality tests and there
haven't been enough of these yet I'm
really encouraging people to do more
comparing Wikipedia to traditional
things we went hands-down so a German
magazine compared German Wikipedia which
is really much much smaller than English
to Microsoft Encarta and to Brockhouse
multimedia and we want across the board
they hired experts to come and look at
articles and compare the quality and we
were very pleased with that result
so a lot of people have heard about the
Wikipedia Bush Carrie controversy this
is a the media has covered this somewhat
extensively started out with a an
article in red herring the reporters
called me up and they I mean I have to
say they spelled my name right but they
they really wanted to say the bush Kerry
election is so contentious is tearing
apart the Wikipedia community and so
they quote me is saying they're the most
contentious in the history of Wikipedia
what I actually said is they're not
contentious at all so it's a slight
misquote the articles were edited quite
heavily and it is true that we did have
to lock the articles on a couple of
occasions
Time magazine recently reported that
extreme action sometimes has to be taken
and whales locked the entries on carrion
Bush for most of 2004 this came after I
told the reporter that we had to lock it
for occasionally a little bit here and
there so the truth in general is that
the kinds of controversies that you
would probably think we have within the
Wikipedia community are not really
controversies at all articles on
controversial topics are edited a lot
but they don't cause much controversy
within the community and the reason for
this is that most people understand the
need for neutrality the the real
struggle yeah the real struggle is not
between the right and the left that's
what most people assume but it's it's
been the party of the thoughtful in the
party of the jerks and no side of the
political spectrum has a monopoly on
either of those qualities the actual
truth about the specific Bush Carrie
incident is that the bush Kerry articles
were locked less than 1% of the time in
2004 and it wasn't because they were
contentious it was just because there
was routine vandalism which happens
sometimes even on stage people sometimes
even reporters have reported to me that
they vandalize Wikipedian were amazed
that it was fixed so quickly and I said
you know I always say please don't do
that that's not a good thing so how do
we do this what how do we manage the
quality control what makes how does it
work so there's a few elements mostly
social policies and some elements of the
software so the the biggest and the most
important thing is our neutral point of
view policy this is something that I set
down from the very beginning as a core
principle of the community that's
completely not debatable it's it's a
social concept of cooperation so we
don't talk a lot about truth and
objectivity the reason for this is if we
say we're only going to write the truth
about some topic that doesn't do us a
damn bit of good of figuring out what to
write because I don't agree with you
about what's the truth but we have this
jargon term of neutrality which has its
own long history within the community
which basically says anytime there's a
controversial issue Wikipedia itself
should not take a stand on the issue we
should merely report on what reputable
parties have said about it
so this neutrality policy is really
important for us because it empowers a
community that is very diverse to come
together and actually get some work done
so we have very diverse contributors in
terms of political religious cultural
backgrounds by having this firm
neutrality policy which is
non-negotiable from the beginning we
ensure that people can work together and
that the entries don't become simply a
war back and forth between the left and
the right if you engage in that type of
behavior you'll be asked to leave the
community
so real-time peer review every single
change on the site goes to the recent
changes page so as soon as he made his
change it went to the recent changes
page that recents changes page I was
also fed into IRC channel which is an
internet chat channel that people are
monitoring with various software tools
and people can get RSS feeds they can
get email notifications of changes and
then users can set up their own personal
watchlist so my page is on quite a few
volunteers watchlist because it is
sometimes vandalized and therefore what
happens is someone will notice the
change very quickly and then they'll
they'll just simply revert the change
there's a new pages feed for example so
you can go to a certain page of
Wikipedia and see every new page as its
created this is really important because
a lot of new pages that get created are
just garbage that have to be deleted you
know asdf asdf but also that's some of
the most interesting and fun things that
wikipedia is some of the new articles
people will start an article on some
interesting topic other people will find
that intriguing and jump in and help and
make it much better so we do have edits
by anonymous users which is one of the
most controversial and intriguing things
about Wikipedia so Chris was able to do
his change he didn't have to login or
anything he just went on the website and
made a change but it turns out that only
about 18% of all the edits to the
website are done by anonymous users and
that's a really important thing to
understand is that the vast majority of
the edits that go on on the website are
from a very close-knit community of
maybe six hundred to a thousand people
who are in constant communication and we
have over 40 IRC channels 40 mailing
lists all these people know each other
they communicate we have offline
meetings these are the people who are
doing the bulk of the site and they are
in a sense semi-professionals at what
they're doing
that the standards that we set for
ourselves are equal to or higher than
professional standards of quality we
don't always meet those standards but
that's what we're striving for and so
that type community is who really cares
for the site and these are some of the
smartest people I've ever met of course
it's my job to say that but it's
actually true the type of people who are
drawn to writing an encyclopedia for fun
tend to be pretty smart people the tools
in the software there's lots of tools
that allow us allow us meaning the
community
to self-monitor and to monitor all the
work this is an example of a page
history on Flat Earth and you can see
some changes that were made what's nice
about this page is it you can
immediately take a look at this and and
see oh okay I understand now when
somebody goes and looks at they see that
someone an anonymous IP number made an
edit to my page that sounds suspicious
who was this person somebody looks at it
they can immediately see highlighted in
red all of the changes that took place
to see okay well this is these words
have changed things like this so that's
one tool that we can use to very quickly
monitor the history of a page another
thing that we do within the community is
we leave everything very open-ended most
of the social rules and the and the
methods of work are left completely
open-ended in the software all of that
stuff is just on wiki pages and so
there's nothing in the software that
enforces the rules the example I've got
up here is a votes for deletion page so
I mentioned earlier people type asdf
asdf it needs to be deleted cases like
that the administrators just delete it
there's no reason to have a big argument
about it but you can imagine there's a
lot of other areas where the question is
is this notable enough to go on
encyclopedia is the information
verifiable is that a hoax is it true is
that what so we needed a social method
for figuring out the answer to this and
so the method that arose organically
within the community is the votes for
deletion page and in the particular
example we have here it's a film twisted
issues and the first person says this is
supposedly a film it fails the Google
test miserably the Google test is you
look in Google and see if it's there
because if something's not even in
Google it probably doesn't exist at all
it's not a perfect rule but it's a nice
starting point for quick research so
somebody says delete it please delete is
not notable then somebody says wait wait
wait wait I found it I found in a book
film threat video guide the 20
underground films you must see ok so the
next person says clean it up somebody
says I found it in IMDB keep keep keep
and what's interesting about this is
that the software is these votes are
just they're just text typed into a page
this is not really a vote at so much it
is a dialogue now it is true that at the
end of the day an administrator can go
through here and take a look at this and
say ok 18 deletes 2 keeps will delete it
but in other cases this could be 18
deletes and 2 keeps and we would keep it
because if those last two keeps saying
wait a minute wait a minute nobody else
saw this but I found it in a book and I
found a link to a page that describes it
and I'm gonna clean it up tomorrow so
please don't delete it then it it would
it would survive
and it also matters who the people are
who are voting I could say it's a
tight-knit community down here at the
bottom keep real movie Rick hey Rick K
is a very famous Wikipedian who does an
enormous amount of work with vandalism
hoaxes and votes for deletion his voice
carries a lot of weight within the
community because he knows what he's
doing so how is all this governed I mean
people really want to know about ok
administrators things like that so the
wikipedia governance model the
governance of the community is a very
confusing but a workable mix of
consensus meaning we try not to vote on
the content of articles because the
majority view is not necessarily neutral
some amount of democracy all of the
administrators these are the people who
have the ability to luli pages that
doesn't mean they have the right to
delete pages they still have to follow
all the rules but they're elected
they're elected by the community
sometimes people random trolls on the
internet like to accuse me of
handpicking the administrators to bias
the content at the encyclopedia I always
laugh at this because I have no idea how
their elected actually there's a certain
amount of aristocracy and so you've got
a hint of that when I mentioned like
Rick Kay's voice would carry a lot more
weight than someone we don't know I give
this talk sometimes with Angela who was
just re-elected to the board from the
community to the board of the foundation
with more than twice the votes of the
person who didn't make it and I always
embarrass her because I say well Angela
for example could get away with doing
absolutely anything within Wikipedia
because she's so admired and so powerful
but the irony is of course that Angela
can do this because she's the one person
who you know would never ever ever break
any rules of Wikipedia and I also like
to say she's the only person who
actually knows all the rules of
Wikipedia so and then there's monarchy
and that's my role in the community so I
I was describing this in in Berlin once
and the next day in the newspaper that
the headline said I am the queen of
England
and that's not exactly what I said but
the point is my role in the community
within the free software world there is
long there's been a long-standing
tradition of the benevolent dictator
model so if you look at most of the
major free software projects they have
one single person in charge who everyone
agrees is the benevolent dictator well I
don't like the the term benevolent
dictator and I don't think that it's my
job or my role in the world of ideas to
be the dictator of the future of all
human knowledge compiled by the world it
just isn't appropriate but there is a
need still for a certain amount of
monarchy a certain amount of sometimes
we have to make a decision and we don't
want to get bogged down too heavily in
formal decision-making processes so as
an example of why this has been or how
this can be important we recently had a
situation where a neo-nazi website
discovered Wikipedia and they said oh
well this is horrible this Jewish
conspiracy of a website and we're gonna
get certain articles deleted that we
don't like and we see they have a voting
process so we're gonna send we have
40,000 members and we're gonna send them
over and they're all gonna vote and get
these pages deleted well they managed to
get 18 people to show up that's neo-nazi
math for you they always think they've
got 40,000 members when they've got 18
but they managed to get 18 people to
come and vote in a fairly absurd way to
delete a perfectly valid article of
course the vote ended up being about 85
to 18 so there was no real danger to our
democratic processes on the other hand
people said well what are we gonna do I
mean this could happen what if some
group gets really seriously organized
and comes in and wants to vote then I
said well it will just change the rules
that's that's my job in the community to
say we won't allow our openness and
freedom to undermine the quality of the
content and so as long as people trust
me in my role then then that's a valid
place for me of course because of the
free licensing if I do a bad job the
volunteers are more than happy to take
and leave I can't tell anyone what to do
so the final point here is that to
understand how Wikipedia works it's
important to understand that our wiki
model is the way
but we are not fanatical web anarchists
in fact our we're very flexible about
the social methodology because it's
ultimately the passion of the community
is for the quality of the work not
necessarily for the process that we used
to generate it thank you Ben Saunders
Jim you mentioned impartiality being a
key to Wikipedia success it strikes me
that much of the the textbooks that are
used to educate our children are
inherently biased have you have you
found Wikipedia being used by teachers
and how do you see Wikipedia changing
education yeah so a lot of teachers are
beginning to use Wikipedia another
there's a there's a media storyline
about Wikipedia which i think is false
it builds on the storyline of bloggers
versus newspapers and the storyline is
there's this crazy thing Wikipedia but
academics hate it and teachers hate it
and that turns out to not be true the
last time I got an email from a
journalist saying why do academics hate
Wikipedia I sent it from my Harvard
email address because I was recently
appointed to follow there and I said
well they don't all hate it but I think
there's gonna be huge impacts and we
actually have a project that I'm
personally really excited about which is
the wiki books project which is an
effort to create textbooks in all the
languages that's a much bigger project
it's gonna take 20 years or so to come
to fruition but part of that is to
fulfill our mission of giving an
encyclopedia to every single person on
the planet we don't mean we're gonna
spam them with AOL style CDs we mean
we're gonna give them a tool that they
can use and for a lot of people in the
world if I give you an encyclopedia
that's written at a university level it
doesn't do you any good without a whole
host of literacy materials to build you
up to the point where you can actually
use it and so the wiki books project
isn't effort to do that and I think that
we're gonna really see a huge it may not
even come from us there's all kinds of
innovation going on but freely licensed
textbooks are the next big thing in
education
what if great ideas weren't cherished
what if they carried no importance or
held no value there is a place where
artistic vision is protected where
inspired design ideas live on to become
ultimate driving machines
you